are we turning to gambling as a quick
fix england legend peter shilton
regardless one of the greatest
goalkeepers of all time kept a dark
secret for much of his life a chronic
gambling addiction
england's most cat player peter shilton
had the world in the palm of his hands a
glittering club career spanning three
decades representing some of britain's
biggest sides at the time winning two
european cups a uefa super cup and a
first division championship
shilton represented england at three
world cups less said about some than
others but shilton was a household name
both home and abroad but behind the fame
and the accolade shilton was living with
a crippling addiction throughout his
playing career he was living a double
life as a gambling addict one that
nearly ruined him not only financially
but mentally and physically
peter shilton joins me now peter
delighted to have you on the show thank
you
um how much have you lost from gambling
i would say it was over 45 years but i
would say it was in into millions really
um
i started i had a real passion for horse
racing that was my thing i didn't really
you know in those days when i started
was no slot machines and that type of
thing
and uh yeah it started out as a hobby
and just gradually got more and more i
owned horses i loved going up the
gallops i loved going to trainers uh
stables and that type of thing but then
the gambling side just accelerated and
obviously
i didn't realize because money fuels
gambling and when you're earning decent
money not like they earn these days but
you know you know that there's plenty of
money coming in and that's
the thing that keeps you going really
somebody once said to me about gambling
and i had a period early on in my life
that you you lie to yourself you lie to
everybody around you you make excuses
you believe that that you know that one
big win is round the corner did you hide
it from your wife steph who by the way
you now credit with with helping you end
this 45-year addiction do you remember
that moment though when you had to admit
to her that so much have been lies and
that you were really in the mind
yeah i mean i'd you know i just i've met
steph and you know we i think we knew
very quickly that uh we were made for
each other you know i was going through
a divorce at the time
and um
to be fair you know we we just literally
sort of
i think steph knew there was something
not right you know because gamblers
you're just touching it we're very
secretive you know you you can keep
secrets you can uh
from anybody you know if you can lie to
yourself you can like actually look yeah
and she knew there was a there was a
problem she'd been in the nhs
and she started working um on me a
little bit you know in terms of trying
to make me realize you know that what i
was doing wasn't right and
it eventually paid off um there was a
moment when i'd had a particularly bad
weekend
and i went upstairs and i was phoning an
agent that i'd done a job for and just
basically saying can you pay me a bit
early i'll give you a drink
and i looked round and steph was behind
me and
i just knew in her face that you know
she she'd so caught me really did you
break down uh yeah we did yeah i finally
said look i've got to stop you know i
know i've got stopped and i don't want
to lose you and and that was she always
said look i would never have left you
but she did make a few you know um
things where she made me feel as though
she might be leaving and and that was
the big thing and also want we wanted to
get married and she says we can't get
married until we sort out you know the
money side of things and and the
security side she talked to my team
about the shock of seeing a bank
statement showing you lost 18 grand um
in one month and how she revealed on one
occasion she found you in the middle of
a night uh in australia in a in a hotel
having an online bet so there was a lot
of duplicity well i was at home looking
at the australia there was a lot of
duplicity yeah yeah definitely i mean
the thing is
you know once i finished playing
football you know and the online started
it even accelerated even more because
she trusts you now pete oh it was seven
and a half years ago when i finished and
i knew myself
you know you
i'd unbelievable amount of effort from
steph you know to make me stop
but i knew myself at the time right why
what was the moment why did you know
after 45 years of gambling and wanting
to make get that rush get that thrill
why did you notice i think i'd had
enough of of losing she used to come in
and say um oh it's the losing racing
post you know and and oh yeah oh you bet
you've lost again today and i kept
thinking to myself well i've i used to
win everything in football you know in
my career well when you when you look at
that the most decorated goalkeeper ever
really the most extraordinary apart from
that cheating thing um but but when you
look at your career
and the adulation that so many felt do
you feel that you sullied that by the
gambling do you feel no because i didn't
have to come out and you know and and
did it affect your game at all no he
never
i had two careers one was football
nothing ever affected football i mean it
was my love it was a you know a job i
was made to do and i you know i i
when i was away from football you know
then i'd sit and in between matches and
gamble and it just gradually got more
and more and more i was going to talk to
you about that i mean
there's a part of me that thinks that
football should be doing a lot more to
stop a generation of gamblers and
drinkers because you know they train for
a couple of hours in the morning these
kids they're on 200 000 pounds a week
they're going to get into trouble do
clubs need to do more do you think oh i
think so definitely i mean it's it's
rife in football
now you know it's it's made for in sport
generally you know it's it's when you're
competing and then you have a period of
you know having to recover and what have
you it's it's made for um you know
keeping on high and
and gambling and and yeah you know it's
it's rife definitely rife now and the
thing is when when you're earning money
people can keep it secret but but
somebody said to me and i didn't know
this until earlier nearly half of
premier league teams were sponsored by
betting companies last season in
newcastle united and my team west ham
what does that do if you've got players
struggling with those sorts of
addictions that sends a powerful message
doesn't it yeah definitely i mean the
the gambling companies uh you know i've
had carl blanche really since 2005 with
you know with um
improved profits that they've just been
able to do what they want you know they
send up different advertising things my
big thing is shirt sponsorship and
football and you know around the grounds
because i think football's got a very
unhealthy
association with gambling considering
it's it's a family game and it's it's
the beautiful game and and football
needs to put itself in order but i think
you know generally that um a lot needs
to do in the government of delaying a
white paper should have been out in
december your wife's death's working
with the government yeah we're doing it
together i mean the reason i came out
was because i i spoke to a charity
called gambling with lives it was run by
people who lost uh loved ones
mid-twenties through committing suicide
from gambling feeling they couldn't stop
that was the main reason and i felt that
if i came out and i said look you know
you can stop it's not easy but if you do
certain things and um that's what my
reason for coming out and i think
obviously steph is he's got a very
caring side and he's very good at
you know understanding people around a
gambler we're looking at steph now you
say she saved you um
when i when i i mean everybody will say
that there comes a moment in the
gambler's life when you realize and
there was something very personal to you
too that clicked it wasn't it yeah i i
think you need a reason to stop you know
and uh you know
steph was definitely my reason um i
think i just got to an age as well where
i've just fed up of um you know sort of
uh
living the life i was because when
you're gambling it's not just money that
you're gambling with it's time you know
you spend all day long
gambling and then losing and it's been a
waste of time um i must move on uh very
briefly i wish i had far more time sky
sports pundit graeme souness uh says he
doesn't regret describing football as a
man's game after chelsea's rather
dramatic draw with tottenham yesterday i
think we've got this just have a quick
all look the game when you see
simulation people throw themselves
together i'm not saying that in two
games today
it's it's a man's game all of a sudden
again and a referee i thought had a
fabulous game other than some people
points out later but i i thoroughly
enjoyed both games today that okay you
know the if there is such thing as a
purist who watches football might get
we've accepted themselves when the two
managers are gonna upset with each other
but
i'm sorry it's professional sport that's
what it's all about you want to and so
much sometimes you're you can let go of
your emotions and embarrass yourself
uh unrepentant later on taught sport
your thoughts on that i know it's a
difficult subject um yeah it is in in a
sense but i think graham was saying
really football used to be a bit more
physical people didn't roll over quite
so much when they got kicked and well
can i jump in and say the lionesses who
won the european championships when they
get kicked up they just got straight
back up again and it's
like exactly and um was he being
misogynistic that's what he's i don't
think so i think he was just saying that
you know football was a bit more of a
man's game it the men's football in the
past but they're you know the lionesses
have done fantastic they're they're you
know in football that's that's their uh
place you know they've won the euros i
mean they're amazing and they show more
than the men's team and one they want
nothing the two are separate but we're
all england and the fans showed that the
the celebration for the for the la for
the ladies for the girls was just as
much as uh for the men peter shelton uh
you've been a hero of mine for a long
time i'm gonna ask one final question
very quick one word answer best player
you ever played against
uh he was a cheat uh
maradona oh you got it thank you peter
shelton for viewers who need advice on
any of the issues raised just then
helpline information is available at
talk dot tv forward slash helplines